some of my earliest memories of my
father are him saying you have to find
something that gets you out of bed in
the morning and I think that's very very
good advice and I think it's also
remarkable and indicative of him that he
would say that to a daughter in the 70s
as readily as he would to his son I was
writing about a world that can seem very
very silly and it sort of contains its
own parody we never required any
exaggeration to make it funny what's
interesting to me is right now in the US
the statistics are the young women for
the first time are out earning young men
and then this will be what I really
wanted to depict was the first time that
a young woman is given a huge
responsibility Billy Wilder is is really
the exemplars the funny and the
heartfelt you know I I love things which
are about smart people the first few
scripts I wrote every scene ended with
well I guess I'll see you in the next
scene just some things that are mark of
a great writer how will you exposition
and how well you do your transition the
people who make movies are actually
desperate for good material they're
desperate and honestly if you write a
brilliant script they really wouldn't
care if you were a 95 year old
grandmother from Duluth
for me my point of entry into Prada is
as much Miranda as it is Andy you know
they're both right and that's really
what you're striving for in a good seen
a lot of writers like the fact that they
have a work place where they can write
in their underwear and sit in their
house all day and I find it's so deeply
depressing if I can't put pants on it's
just it's a bad day it means I have the
flu i don't i don't like it